first challenge in a very very long time
playing while hula hooping
this is the perfect first challenge
because it gets you warmed up yeah
get your hips moving yeah
the footwork makes it some footwork
[Music]
i have to move
little by little
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh i know
give me to the middle
okay
[Music]
this must be one of the most stupid
looking things we've done
[Music]
[Applause]
so many ways you can do this
[Music]
[Laughter]
let's do a few around the nets
[Music]
dynamite
[Music]
sideways table
oh
i didn't expect this to be this hard
yeah
we got five
yes
[Music]
let's try some juggling
i can't even see anything i just need to
focus on the balls
[Music]
yes
one
[Applause]
okay we can get three
[Music]
good save
[Applause]
[Music]
i got a point good enough
so we have just launched our own racket
and racket case these are some really
cool products go and check them out from
pongfinity.store until next time
[Music]
[Applause]
you learn something new every day i can
put that on my cv